here's what's awesome about being a
writer
people will follow you if it feels like
what's happening to the characters feels
emotionally honest i mean you really can
make
almost anything happen i'm opening the
doors to my office so that the next
generation of writers can exist
how to put together a television pilot
writing dialogue
character how a writer's room works i
would have killed to know that
it would have made things easier on me
and i probably would have been less
afraid
i have never gone into this much detail
about my process
you have to think about your first 10
pages being all about who is my
character how do i reveal my character
as best as i possibly can
take a pilot that you know well and
break it down and so i thought we would
do that with a scandal pilot
dialogue is almost everything if you
don't want it to sound like tv
really listen to the conversations of
people around you become an eavesdropper
i graduated from college and really felt
lost
i mean truly felt lost i used to drive
around the corner from the studio and
cry all lunch hour and i would come home
at the end of a very long day and i
would pull out my laptop and i would
work on my script
that script is a script that got me an
agent that got me a job that got things
happening for me
there are so many people out there who
feel like television has these you know
secret keys to its kingdom let's take
those keys and unlock the doors
let's figure out what's back there i'm
gonna tell you what i know
what you should be doing right now is
sitting down to start writing
immediately remember that you belong in
any room that you enter and if you don't
feel like you truly belong
act like you belong it should be okay to
not feel like you're getting it right
all the time because nobody ever is i
think a lot of people are stopped by the
idea of perfection like i must know this
or i must know that
nothing has to be perfect just right
i'm shonda rhimes and this is my master
class
[Music]
you